it's awesome it's like the coolest
puppet I wanted to take them home
national food animals
National Lampoon's Animal House was my
very very first movie I was an acting
student in New York and I didn't have an
agent I was probably about 18 I think
maybe the casting director did something
that was sort of unusual where they went
to the school and asked the people that
ran the school if they had any
suggestions for college students
wet-behind-the-ears I remember them
remember that being in a description and
they sent me over and I met John Landis
and there was a word that was used
either in the in this in the script or
maybe in the in the way they described
the character in the audition which was
smarmy and it's not a word that I was
familiar with I didn't know what it
meant but I thought to myself I can kind
of think of what smarmy might mean so I
just made a face that was what I thought
maybe smarmy was and John lands is like
I love that I love that smarmy do the
smart thing and that's the part and it
just kind of blew my mind but a lot of
outstanding guys figure they'll pledge
Omega or they won't pledge at all
well sure everybody I talked to says
Omega is the best I hate to seem you
know pushy I was working as a waiter at
the time and so I quit my job and I went
out and you know spent I guess five
weeks having this magical kind of
experience making making a movie and the
whole thing was pretty overwhelming when
I came back to New York I thought to
myself that's it baby I am set I'm a I'm
a movie star and then I didn't work on I
didn't work for months and months and
months after that and so I had to get my
job back at the restaurant so when the
movie actually came out I was a waiter
and I had to ask for the night off to go
to the premiere
premier was someplace in Times Square
and when I got there I saw the rest of
the cast who most of them have lived in
California and they'd flown the rest of
the cast and and there was a red red
carpet and there was the the red rope
and I was on the other side of it
because there was a kind of a hierarchy
of what kind of tickets you got or
something like that and I just had the
the [ __ ] tickets to the to the premiere
it was actually a kind of a super super
humbling kind of night for me you know I
mean funny in retrospect but at the time
I was sort of horrified because I
figured that I was you know one of the
stars we technically wasn't Footloose
Footloose definitely was a breakthrough
all it was a turning point in part that
was like one of those life-changing kind
of things where like all of a sudden you
go from being an actor that some people
know to being you know a pop star at
that point in my life you know when I
when I first you know wanted to become
an actor I really wanted to be a pop
star that's really one of the reasons
that I did it
but by that point in my life I'd studied
so much and I take done so much theater
and I'd taken this thing so seriously
that there was a last thing in the world
I wanted to be in retrospect I could
have embraced it you know a little bit
more but it was a great opportunity we
were out in Utah you know in a
completely Mormon community all living
it at a motel together the cast the the
physical challenges of you know learning
you know as much of these dance moves as
I could and and and some of the
gymnastics and all that kind of stuff I
remember when I got the part I said to
the director listen you know I see that
there's these dance things in here you
could get a choreographer if you want to
but like I'd like to dance why you just
turn on the camera I'll just dance
around I had no idea that it was going
to be like this kind of choreographed
thing I just didn't get that I thought
it was just like they they just said oh
the kid just dances around
[Music]
I had so many doubles during that
warehouse it was really like it was like
a real identity crisis because I had a
dance double that I had I think two
gymnastic doubles who did different
sorts of things one guy could do one
flip oh my god you could do with
something else and then I also had a
stunt double after a while you kind of
go why am I even here
like I mean somebody got to come in and
double me on the acting I saw a funny
warehouse scene parody who was it hot
rod that's where it was yeah yeah yeah
Sam yeah exactly any sane program yeah
that's right in the forest that's a
great I saw that I love that that was
hilarious
it was so good I totally I knew that too
I really thought it was so good
I saw the remake and you know frankly I
think the dancing and the remake is
better than the dancing in the original
you know because the thing about the
thing about Footloose the movie was that
I was not a trained dancer nor was Chris
Penn or Laurie singer or really any of
the cast I mean I guess Sarah Jessica
Parker maybe had done some dancing but
but but in in the remake of Footloose
those are the answers I mean though they
cast dancers so so their dancing ability
is kind of way beyond mine it was a
great opportunity and I look back fondly
on the on the movie for sure
x-men first class
just right off the bat the whole idea of
the Marvel kind of the world and you
know these guys come these be kind of
nerdy guys come and they've got this
giant stack of every single time that
the character has ever been mentioned
already every single you know cell that
you've ever seen of him throughout all
the history of the x-men comic books and
and so I'm like wow okay so this is my
research it is kind of fun to have that
to dig into that and that Vaughn is a
real interesting character the guy that
directed the movie you know takes a long
time and it's it's kind of painstaking
in in the sense of you know you're
you're really at the mercy of effects
and and and certainly there's a lot of
cooks when it comes to doing it's almost
right in that big a check you know but
you know I got to say I did my superhero
movie then didn't insane Nishi be texts
she's
fish tastes - eins mama yes
spy
I'll assist booth
drive yeah boom bah bah I had to learn
German and for that scene and then after
I did the German scene that said to me
you know you got that scene where you
talking to the Russian guys haven't you
speak Russian and that I was like ok the
German was hard enough may I ask you
something why are you on their side yeah
that was probably about three or four
days in a completely green room because
all those mirrors and stuff were all
created you know Michael is yeah it's a
great actor and frankly in some ways
those scenes were in some ways easier
for me because at least we had stuff you
know we had good stuff to play you know
and I loved you know going through that
with him
it was it was it was good I don't wanna
hurt you her I never did
I would help you this is our time our
age we are the future of the human race
tremors when I got tremors my wife was
pregnant with our first child and my mom
was sick and my career I felt was in the
app absolutely [ __ ] and I was running
out of money and feeling like a lot of
pressure
I remember just kind of talking to my
wife and we were having a conversation
and almost like just kind of like
breaking down you know on on about 89th
of Broadway I'd say to her can't believe
I'm doing a [ __ ] movie about underground
worms
there's the only character that really
that I've ever played that I really
wanted to go back and revisit I was
really proud to have been in it and back
in those days there were these things
that you kids don't know about they're
called video tapes and video was
exploding and tremors was one of the
first movies that took a [ __ ] at the box
office and just exploded on video we
killed it when they came to me about
doing tremors - I was like I'm not gonna
do tremors - termos one was a bomb you
know I don't I don't want to do a part
two of a movie that didn't do well the
first time around you know they ended up
making eight of those diner in 98 - yeah
I got this movie diner which was one of
the greatest experiences I think of my
you know acting life and and I had an
agent finally by that point and they
were casting a pretty wide net because
they had to put together this this group
of young men in their 20s and they had
what five five roles that were available
so the process was like this you you you
went in and I guess we we got a chance
to read the script and then pick the
part that you wanted to audition for I
immediately had two ideas one was boogie
which was a part that Mickey Rourke
ended up doing because boogie was like
super cool he was tough and he was you
know kind of a badass and I thought well
that's that's cool I want to do that and
the other was Billy which is the part
that Tim Daly did because he was a
romantic and there was some you know
kind of romance involved in girls and I
thought well that's that's that's the
other thing that I would want to give a
shot and I wondered and I read both of
those for Barry Levinson and Barry said
go ahead go out go out and look at fed
work and I was kind of disappointed
because I didn't really have a handle on
that work if Emily didn't have a lot of
line and I went back in and I got the
call back and I had about a hundred and
four fever I was really sick with the
flu but it was the only day there was no
you know there was no choice to come
back nothing so I think that part of
what got me the part was the flu because
the character who finally really kind of
discovered when I was talking to Barry
about it was that he has a low level of
drunk throughout the whole thing so
really I was just like you know kind of
just sort of out of it anyway I took
that with the flu on that sleepers
part of being an actor is being able to
tap into our darker side this is a side
that you know I think I think all of us
as human beings we have pain anxiety
fear extreme you know thoughts and and
and desires but we just don't act on
them generally you know we just have
these kind of feelings that sometimes
infiltrate our minds or our brains or
what waking or our subconscious and you
just have to be able to not be afraid of
that sort of as an actor and and I
actually find that going to dark places
is sort of therapeutic in a way because
it kind of I've been able to like purge
myself of you know sad fearful angry
violent kind of you know feelings as
opposed to pressing them down pressing
down pressing them down pressing down
it's it's an outlet so this character is
not unlike that you know Barry Levinson
directed me a diner came back to me many
years later and one of the few people
that never hired me twice and had me
read the book as I'm reading this book
I'm seeing and there's all these cool
guys you know that ended up being played
by Brad Pitt and Billy Crudup and on and
on I'm like huh that's not that part you
know it's not that for its good coming
up soon no it's not that far
oh it's the abusive you know prison
guard great okay now I know
Nokes all I had to do is look at the
name ago I know what he wants me to do
scared shitless why I tried to make you
tough I tried to make you hard
why had you all wrong then that's all
this time I thought you just liked
[ __ ] and beating up little boys you
two [ __ ] are gonna burn in hell
you can burn in hell
f tu oh did that hurt knows I've been
squid before but I'd never had seven
squibs a squib is basically you know
it's a it's a it's a little it's
gunpowder it's a little charge but it's
it's like it's like a gunshot that goes
off of you as opposed to in you in
theory they put seven of them on and
there's a little blood pack so that it
you know pops open they said something
about wearing a bulletproof vest and I
was like but aren't they supposed to go
out this way but there were I did have
some some not not not life-threatening
but there definitely were some burns on
my chest after that after that I think I
remember that being a pretty cool scene
I had a funny experience with one of
those kids where I got to this
television show sitting on a hill and
and here's this guy's all grown up and
I'm looking at am I gonna heck I looks
familiar he was one of the kids Jonathan
Tucker
yeah he was in sleepers when he was
probably about I don't know 10 11
something like that you know and now
he's I'm trying to put him away you know
in the he's a bank robber so it's cool
great actor action
I'll tell you when you're hungry or that
eat listen you know I'm not afraid I'm
not I'm not afraid to play in anything
I'm really not you know if I think it's
good and interesting and and I haven't
done it before I'll do it phew goodness
you good men was you know beautiful
perfect kind of script from Aaron Sorkin
that had been a play and there were a
few different roles that I was kind of
looking at in that script and and my
wife is the one that's said to me you
gotta play this guy he's a good guy's a
stand-up guy
to me you know I'm often like drawn to
the darker kind of characters and I'm
afraid sometimes that if somebody's just
stand up and goes follows a straight and
narrow that's just not gonna be
interesting but she was absolutely right
did you ever actually hear lieutenant
Kendrick order a Code Red
no sir please the court I'd like to
request a recess in order to confer with
my client why did you go into Santiago's
right the witness has been read his
rights commander the question will be
repeated why on earth antiag o--'s room
hell did Lance Corporal Dawson tell you
to give Santiago a Code Red
how don't look at him shooting with
Robin with Tom and to me and Nicholson
you know I'm getting to to work with
Jack it was such a kind of hero of mine
you know when I was deciding to become
an actor his performances were very very
influential to me because he was
probably the first actor that I ever saw
that you could tell he just didn't he
could play the lead and still not give a
[ __ ] if anybody liked them or not you
know he had no problem it's not like he
was trying to be handsome or dynamic or
charming or chemistry or be likable you
could just see that he just didn't care
you know the movie was almost like doing
a play because we rehearsed it on a
soundstage with while the set was being
built with the set sort of taped out and
the props and all this kind of stuff and
we rehearsed it in in a fairly
you know theatrical way and when we got
to actually shooting it Rob was so well
prepared and everything was so well
broken down at his head that the days
were really flowed you know it's it's we
didn't have any crazy long days and we'd
have nice you know lunches in his office
and we would spend time together on the
weekends and stuff it was a pleasure to
make that one Flatliners Flatliners was
a really interesting idea and Joel
Schumacher was kind of the top of his
game at that time and joy Roberts was
just exploding I mean it was literally
like I think during shooting or
something like that pretty woman came
out and she just became an absolute
superstar it was one of those ones where
you you know even though we weren't kids
you put a bunch of us together and the
end the hours were long and you've got
Oliver Platt and Kiefer and Julie and
Billy Baldwin anion and for such a dark
movie there was a lot of laughs I mean
to the point where sometimes we couldn't
actually pull it together and then you
get in trouble
Friday the 13th
Friday the 13th you know listen that was
it was another iconic film because it
was the very first one we shot the movie
in Blair's town New Jersey which was you
know on the other side of the George
Washington Bridge and kind of out in the
sticks and there was no transportation I
think they would drop me off on the way
back at a bus stop and I'd have to get
the bus stop and try to get get back to
Manhattan I was doing a play down in the
village so every day I would shoot I'd
be like terrified that I was gonna miss
the missed the half-hour and the curtain
for the for the show downtown and
probably did a couple of times I had the
classic horror movie death in that
because I had sex and then smoked the
joint and as soon as that happens to
somebody in a horror movie especially if
they're you you know a young person
they're dead I would say the number one
photograph that shoved in front of me by
by fans to sign is a photograph of me
dead from Friday 13th I've got the arrow
coming through my throat and I'm covered
in blood and it's always been a little
strange to me that what people really
want is for me to sign a picture of me
dead
well first off meryl streep to me is the
greatest American actor and the actor
that if I could name any actor that I
would aspire to be like it would be her
because she is so transformational of
course the not surprisingly she's the
person that will put everybody at ease
like immediately and make you feel like
all of our jobs are important i love
john c reilly James for Theron I mean a
fantastic group of people to be working
with and we had the challenges of this
incredible physical kind of thing to go
down this river again and again and
again and again and we're shooting in
Montana and we were supposed to go to
Oregon but Oregon would not let us bring
helicopters into the sections of the
river we wanted to shoot that were
designated Wild and Scenic so the
director decided that we would stay for
another month two months in this tiny
town called Libby Montana and there was
a section of this river that was
completely Kootenai River it was
completely unnavigable it was just a
series of waterfalls you couldn't take a
raft down there you would never survive
and that's the section that we used
it was often terrifying I'm not gonna
lie I mean you know we got to the point
where once we had been thrown from the
boat and I survived the rapid it made it
a little bit easier in a way because you
kind of knew that it was possible to
survive and you know we were training we
had training and stuff like that but
they experimented with having they built
a life mask that they would then glue on
to the stuntman and like a of both of me
and Johnse but it didn't work because
basically what you have is this this
doesn't look like anything so you can't
really use it you know there's a couple
of moments where there's probably some
doubles but it was pretty much us all
the time Apollo 13 Apollo 13 was an
incredible experience the research that
goes into trying to figure out how to
throw astronaut terminology around
that's not the way my brain sort of
works Tom Hanks I think actually could
probably fly the space shuttle at this
point if he wanted to because he was
really was a space freak and knew a lot
about it the late great Bill Paxton was
was in that and we spent a lot of time
with the three of us in a capsule you
know and had an amazing time the most
amazing thing about doing Apollo 13 was
that there's an airplane called the
kc-135 that nASA uses in order to train
astronauts in zero-gravity there's no
way to duplicate gravity on earth except
for flying out over the Gulf of Mexico
and climbing straight up and then diving
and as you go over the top of this dive
the centrifugal force and the
gravitational pull balance out for 26
seconds so you can see what it feels
like to float we were gonna try to do it
with like you know harnesses and the
usual stuff which you know nowadays
would be really really easy but back
then making it look good the technology
was nowhere near where we're
right now we're on Howard came to us and
said so guys I would speak talking to
Spielberg it's be a blur said to me why
don't you just shoot when he just build
the set on the kc-135 and you can shoot
up there on the Vomit Comet they called
the vomit calm because it's incredibly
nauseating sure enough that's what we
did we did we did it 600 times hey we've
got a problem here what did you do
nothing I stirred the tanks whoa this is
Houston say again please houston we have
a problem we would go up at lunch with
the camera crew kind of a minimal camera
crew the set was built there and we
would just shoot all of the weight in
those weightless scenes and we do
probably 40 in the morning out to out
turn around and do 40 back land have
lunch go back to do 40 and 40 back and
get about 80 a day and that's that's how
we got all over the weightless footage
we did the fun way yeah for sure
I took the part kind of because of the
scene where I'm sitting on the bench
with the little girl because I thought
to myself if I can make this moment work
then I can back the whole movie up from
there and I thought it was so well
written and so chilling a moment the
kinds of characters that they are the
darkness that they they feel are the
things that they've done I don't I'm not
scared of it you know and I don't worry
about well that's gonna make me look bad
make Kevin look bad to me that's the
difference between an actor and a movie
star or a celebrity my daddy lets me sit
on his lap
does he yes do you like it when he asks
you know
why not
one of the things that I think is is
important about that part is that so
often you'll hear it when when people
discuss things on the news or they talk
about or they write reviews or they used
this is a line that's often used in in
dialogue
they'll call people monsters that guy's
a monster this one's a monster that was
a monstrous thing monsters are not
frightening because they're not real you
know monsters like are the things that
comes in and a guy has a laser gun
adapted right if there were really
monsters and the girl would call
superhero these are people human beings
so to me it was really about trying to
humanize something that is repulsive and
and so such a hot-button issue for for
for us as viewers as parents I mean that
was what was important to me about doing
the film was to try to see if I could
make this guy the human being Holloman
seems like an easy gig gig invisible man
right because you know have to learn any
lines no you have to learn the lines you
ghosts don't have to be there I thought
to myself this is gonna be the world's
easiest gig because I'll just say it in
post and it became pretty clear to me
pretty early that it was actually going
to be incredibly hard and it was it was
probably the hardest thing I've ever
done
I was the green-screen so I was covering
green and green giant green contact
lenses green green makeup green teeth
and then a green suit and it was just
really hard to wear that from month
after month after month and then I had
to wear a once I poured the latex over
my head that thing had to be glued to my
mouth and I couldn't eat all day and I
found that to be a very very challenging
very talented
[Music]
authorization please okay zero zero two
seven confirmed thank you I can't let
you leave sorry babe
you don't have a choice mr. Griffin for
me was without a doubt one of the most
fun experiences I've ever had we got an
opportunity to work with Clint who was
one of the greats both as an iconic
movie star and also as a as a film
director and there's nobody that has
really when you compare it has that kind
of superstardom as an actor at the same
time started directing when he was a
very very young man and direct film
after filming must be must be up to 35
thumbs up or something like that no and
you know even really successful
directors don't get a chance to direct
35 films if they're just directors and
he's an actor too I mean it's he's
really remarkable we all realized really
quickly that there was no rehearsal and
sometimes Clinton would shoot the first
take and that would be it you'd move on
or he'd shoot the rehearsal or he'd just
turned the camera on and wouldn't tell
anybody the camera was on we had to come
to work with the game Jersey on a
hundred percent ready to go and we
started to have our own rehearsals
believed we would go up to somebody's
room at the hotel we were all staying at
and it was it was also he shoots so
quickly that there was a lot of time in
the bar and probably too much but we had
a blast it was really a fun it was a fun
show dark was the dark day yeah that was
that was a dark day but again you know
Sean came so ready to play that and
Clint rate came so ready with
how he wanted to shoot it but it's not
like like when everyone is that
well-prepared both on the acting side of
things the emotion that you have to put
yourself through is you know there's
gonna be an end to it because you know
this day is not gonna last forever so
it's when it's really hard as when you
feel like the director doesn't know he's
like yeah dude that a kid you like I
just I was just I just put it all I just
left it all on the field and now you
want me to do it again well I didn't
quite get this angle or you know I mean
it's like that custom there's none of
that so yeah it was it was dark it was a
dark day but you know yeah everybody got
through
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah we have it that that was one of
those scenes where we had to get down on
the ground
and have this kind of like wrestling
match and somebody started to laugh and
holy [ __ ] we could not get through it
we were laughing so hard because it just
was strangely like intimate you know
because we were all rolling around
together excuse me Emily left her
sweater in my car the other night
Oh who are you I'm David Lynn hug baby
Lynn Hagen David okay is this a bad time
yeah not much pain and suffering you
caused my friend
I just remember it being one of those
like thank you everyone's laughing and
then tips and then you start to see the
producers like a looking at their
watches and the directors starting to
get a little irritated and you know but
but yeah it was fun I had a good time
the following the thing about the
following was is it up until that point
I
I was completely opposed to doing
television at all I came up at a time
when television was kind of like the
that's where he went to when your career
died that's where you went to have your
career die basically you know all of a
sudden I realized that the idea to be
able to you know expand on a character
over multiple seasons was really kind of
fun I mean we're not gonna see that a
movie script you know I'm only gonna
have so many scenes to tell the story of
who this man is
Mike Ryan back off don't don't do this
cause you're better than this
Mike your good man
put the gun down take me into custody
you're on Lily
I used to be Valen was a very intense
show to shoot I would have dark you know
[ __ ] up dreams and it put me in the
dark place see beyond a city on a hill
is a television show on Showtime that I
that I play a character named Jackie
Brewer who is another FBI agent who's
corrupt and nothing he there's never a
scene the Jackie is in where he doesn't
isn't doing something despicable or
saying something inappropriate or
stabbing somebody in the back or taking
money under the table or doing drugs or
drinking or philandering Jackie brought
FBI you mind if I call you Dee no I
haven't rain Ramos when I want to talk
to you about you got a kid roach on your
dog and he's an informant of mine he's
working a decent case he always was shot
a cop well he allegedly shot a cop it's
a great part it's a great part you
should have left
[Music]
you should have left is a story that is
based on a German book that my friend
Dave and I optioned and it was kind of
one of those strange serendipitous
things where we were developing a story
about a horror horror scary kind of
movie that surrounds a marriage and
happened to read this this German book
and it was so close to where we were
already were in our discussions about
what this film could be that we were
kind of better off just getting you know
getting an option on the book which is
what we did and Dave is a fantastic
writer and had directed me years ago in
stir of echoes which was one of my
favorite movie experiences in a really
really excellent scary movie coming out
and I don't know I've seen him over the
fall